Patty is with us in Washington hi Patti
how are you hi Dave and thank you for
your service we have listened to you for
years so we are debt-free and we did
thank you for your service thank you
you're welcome
my husband and I are both retired I'm 65
he's 73 and our annual income is 50,000
a year between his Social Security and
retirement my question is should I defer
my Social Security I'll be able to draw
2,000 a year a month next year when I'm
66 or should I defer mine and draw half
of his which would be about 750 a month
and then drama mine would be about 3,000
when I'm 70
we do have 50,000 in savings 65,000 in a
401 K and we need to get with an ELP and
get those into some mutual funds right
now they're just we're not drawing
anything really well there's two ways of
looking at it okay if you delay it and
get 3,000 and then you live a long long
time
you know you probably come out ahead
that way the longer you live the better
that plan is mathematically okay it's a
better plan anyway but it's a better
plan for the math then the other aspect
of it is if you went ahead and started
taking it now basically you've got about
$50,000 two years of $2,000 a month
would be $48,000 right okay
that $48,000 invested if it made 10
percent would make about five or six
hundred bucks a month okay okay roughly
and so somewhere in that range and so it
won't quite make up the difference but
here's the other thing when you die that
$50,000 is in your estate when you die
with Social Security you get nothing
and so if you were willing to bank all
of it into good mutual funds it probably
is better to go ahead and take it
and Bank it okay obviously taking it and
spending it there's no mathematical
advantage to that at all you don't need
the money is what you're telling me
right so it's just a question of the
math now that is offset somewhat the
longer you live the first first plan
yeah I mean if you lived in 95 the first
plan is going to come out better but if
you live to 75 or 80 my plan is going to
come out taking the money now and
banking it's going to come out better so
I generally say take it and bank it but
it's not like there's an open-and-shut
case of which way to do it necessarily
either way is going to be okay
especially given the fact that you guys
are living on less than you make but I
like having the cash in my name instead
of in the government's name and by
pulling that 2 years worth of income
setting that 48 thousand dollars or so
into a mutual fund that money's mine
forever and ever and if somebody
Congress decides they're going to chop
on Social Security to try to get things
to balance or something I don't know
that they're going to I'm not predicting
that but you don't have any of that risk
then it's your money you now own it
you're not depending on them to give you
a raise or will do whatever else so I
like the idea of taking it early and
investing it because I like control it's
that simple
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind